και κλοφορήσει αμέσως μετά τοπασ κλείνοντας πέράσε και ώρα χωρίς το καταλαβοαλιι άλλη μια μεγάλη
στο αγάπη νε το απόλ ναι θέλαωσ σοαντρέαμου ωκάπου πληγόνει αυτές τις μέρες ς καταφέραμε
από τους οκτό το τάμπιος λίγ να πάμε στους οχτη στην ομάδα των οκτώ που
θα φέρει την επόμενη μέρα τα αξιρασμή μείνουμε στους οκτώ ή πορεία στους οκτό του
τσάμπιονλίκ αν θα τη δούμενα όπως βλέπουμε ταγραφήματα στε όλα τα γραφήματα έχεις φτάνει στην
κορύφωση αυτό πυ ακολουθεί μετά την κορύφωση είναι είναι υπθώσι εείναι ενομοτελιακό σίγουρα εμπορούσαμε να
μην είμαστε σήμερα σε αυτή την τραγική κατάσταση που βρίσκεται το απο έλκαι λέωτραγική διότι
σε περιήρσαν κι άλλες περιότη δύσκολες στην ιστορία τηςτης ομάδας υπήρσ νυπερίτωτησης τότι που πήγα
να πιάσουν θα τρόπας και τον τα ατρόπιατόότε όμως ήταν οι εκρεμότητες ήταν τέτοιουμε γέθους
που ευβρίσκοντα τρεις τέσθερις με βαθές και έπεσης στο απου έλκιε μπορούσαν να σώσουν την
ομάρασήμερα τα μεγέθει είναι εντελώ διαφορετικά ο ανταγωνισμός ίναι εντελώς διαφορετικός δηλαδή βλέπουμε την πάφων
και τον άρην να έχουν πολύ σοβαρά χρήματα επενδημένα και πολύ σοβαρές δικήσεις για να
με δίκαιος δεν είναι μόνο ταλευτά έχουν κάνε και καλή δουλειά οργανωτικά και το π
ελεμείνε πίσω τα από λεμεινε πίσω συνεχίσαμε ν αυτή την παλιά προσύλοσύνστον αποιάνουμε τίτλους αλλά
να μεδιορθνουμε τίποτε μέσα στον οργανισμό και όταν περάσουν τέσθερα χρόνια νααπέξει στην ευρώπι και
να χάσεις και ένα θκι ότίτλους οικονομικά πλέωνίς εδώ που είμαστε σημκαι σήμερα υγάνουμε το
γέρισμα περιμένουμε τις επόμενες μέρες εξελίξεις θεωρίς ότι θα είναι εύκολη επόμενη μέρα στο απόελσίγουρα
όχι ελπί ζω η επόμενη μέρα